okay this is not exactly a major
headline but I I do need to address it
um I don't know if I need to but I will
yesterday The Babylon B posted an
article with this
headline Trump promises VC an
Administration position running the
White House
7-Eleven and you can see the screenshot
there uh with with the picture with the
accompanying photo and the photo is what
really sells it I think that's what
takes it over the top and taken together
you know you have to admit like it's
kind of funny
um I mean it has to at least get a smirk
out of you right and yet if you look at
the comments under this post you'll find
that lots of people are offended by it
and to be clear the people offended are
for the most part people on the right
conservatives okay a bunch of
conservatives are in fact think the
Babylon B is trending right now because
a bunch of conservatives are complaining
that this joke is racist and in bad
taste and not ironically I mean there
are some complaining ironically I did
leave a comment saying I was reporting
The Babylon being of the FBI for hate
crimes but uh many of these comments are
not ironic and not meant to be a joke so
let me just read a few of the just just
thousands of them but let me just read a
few um I'm 100% Trump and think Babalon
be is a National Treasure but this one
is just stupid you can and should do
better a public retraction seems
appropriate here but I'll still look
forward to your
stuff uh someone else says I like the
bee but this was kind of in poor taste
low blow from The Babylon be someone
else says so is the joke that Trump
values him so poorly that he only sees
him as a clerk at 7-Eleven or that you
think he's a clerk at 7-Eleven because
of a tired stereotype about Indian
people uh and there's a bunch that say
not funny this is not
funny and someone I I love this these
types of jokes aren't
helpful aren't helpful you know because
you know the most important thing about
comedy is that it's help
helpful we've all been to like a standup
show and then and then you leave and
somebody asks you how it was and you go
oh it was great it was super helpful so
helpful I just love the comedy show
because it help it was so
helpful um anyway lots of comments like
that uh e Echo it's like this is the
left's language you know do better do
better this is this is this is how you
define this is like number one way you
can spot a this many times is is if they
respond to a joke with that phrase
specifically do better not funny do
better next
time and um again these are comments for
the most part not from the left I mean
these are people on the right uh
actually offended by this very tame joke
so let me just
clarify a few three things
one this is an old school you know
ethnic stereotype joke okay it's like
it's an olding it
is but old school ethnic stereotype
jokes are almost always at least mildly
amusing I don't think I've ever heard
one that wasn't at least kind of
amusing it's it's it's a it's a classic
like these are Classics for a reason and
uh uh you know these these uh in fact
these dated ethnic stereotype jokes are
only becoming funnier like they're
they're increasing in funniness so you
know uh the these old ethnic stereotype
jokes have always been like kind of
funny and then and then you know you
could you could follow the trajectory
and then they kind of I I'd say they
they were the least funny about 20 years
ago because that was about 20 years ago
like everybody was saying them and so
they're not as funny anymore they're
still pretty funny but they're not as
funny because everyone but now people
are actually offended by them again and
so that just makes them more funny like
the fact that nobody else would make
that joke anymore even even The Simpsons
has apologized right that was that whole
uh what was that
documentary The the problem with a poo
and someone put out a
documentary talking about how a whole
documentary about how aoo the the Indian
character is problematic and so they
they like apologized and I think they
took him from out of the show or they he
doesn't run the 7-Eleven anymore I don't
know I don't watch I stopped watching
The Simpsons 25 years ago um and so in
in that environment it only becomes more
funny again so that's the first thing
and um is that most of the people
offended by this joke are are V fans and
uh you should know that V Ras Swami
himself is not offended he put out a
tweet laughing about it as you would
expect like you would not expect him I
mean if he had been offended if he if he
had tweeted himself saying do better
guys this this is not this is too far my
opinion of him would have entirely
changed I would I would go that
alone like this is everything good I've
said about him in that moment I was say
never mind um but he didn't say that he
as expected he uh he thought it was he
thought it was funny so you don't need
to be his white knight Galloping in on
your Gallant Steed to defend him from
The Babylon B headline are you
struggling with back taxes or have
unfiled returns this year the IRS is
escalating collections by adding 20,000
new agents in these challenging times
your best offense is to use tax Network
USA with over 14 years of experience tax
Network USA has saved their clients over
$1 billion in back taxes they specialize
in negotiating with the IRS and aim to
reduce your debt
significantly tax Network USA doesn't
just negotiate they protect your assets
from IRS seizures and uh they manage
your yearly returns for ongoing
compliance importantly they are licensed
to help with all state tax issues
regardless of where you live in the US
seize control of your financial future
now and don't let tax issues overpower
you contacts tax Network USA contact tax
Network USA for immediate relief and
expert guidance call 1800 245 6000 or
visit TN usa.com Walsh turn tax Network
USA and find your path to financial
peace of mind that's TN usa.com Walsh
and also in general being a supporter of
a politician this to me is the most
important thing being a supporter of a
politician should not mean that you are
offended by jokes about that politician
all politicians should be mocked as a
general principle uh and that is as
American as it gets even though ones you
like and I like V ramaswami and he's I
guess he's not technically a politician
at the moment because he just dropped
out but um even so this is this
is what makes us AER what sets us apart
or used to is that we are cynical
towards our politicians and we love
making fun of them if we like them we
make fun of them too and that's and that
is one of the things that's supposed to
be uniquely American right in our
approach um and so to me it's almost
like complaining when a politician is
made fun of it's
anti-American uh in my mind now if the
joke is not really even a joke like a
lot of the jokes quote unquote that you
hear about Trump on late night shows and
stuff you can complain about those jokes
because not because you're offended for
on Trump's but just because they're
actually not funny because they're not
even really jokes there's no attempt to
make a joke here they're like Jimmy
Kimmel for the for the 50th time doing a
a monologue where it's supposed to be a
joke but it's just one long whine um
yeah that's just not funny that's
actually not funny because there's no
joke being told anywhere in it U so I
you couldn't laugh even if you wanted to
that's one thing but this is clearly
it's coming from The Babylon be you know
that's a friendly Source like clearly
it's a it's a joke that's what it's
supposed to be and uh and that's how it
should be taken and the third thing is
just and this is this is I
admit the people reacting to a Babylon B
headline um it's a pretty minor issue
All Things Considered but it is a small
microcosm of something that worries me a
lot which is that some corners of the
right are truly becoming as woke as the
left this is one
little another bit of evidence so if you
were worried about that it's just one
little one one one one small bit of
evidence that would seem to confirm that
um very disturbing suspicion that you
that this is ha on on on the right this
is this there is this
mentality and it to me it seems to be
getting worse over time you got someone
on the right who are you know they're
kind of backing away from some of these
cultural issues they don't want to talk
about them anymore they're softening
their
stances um they're on on you know
they're they're getting offended or
pretending to be offended by really tame
ethnic jokes and that sort of
thing um
so that's something that we
should watch out for it's very
concerning thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast